look
[Music]
how does cristian cásseres consumption greet you
with his news report in
spanish last night donald trump's president
publicly acknowledged his defeat in the
elections last night the president reported
through a video published by the
white house that there will be  a peaceful transition of power
to president-elect joe biden
on january 20th
trump also condemned the violence of
his supporters
on investors announced more layoffs for
his properties here in las vegas' this
time has impacted more than 100
supervisors but still analysts
expect  hope the local economy improves
over the next six months
well the las vegas metro police
are looking for a suspect
responsible for a fatal shooting it all
happened at a strip mall on
carlsten streets between the am inn it's
around 7 o'clock
Thursday night officials report that a man
was shot outside a business but
details of the reason are unknown.  know of
any information that could help the
investigation you are asked to call
crime stoppers
well las vegas police are also
investigating a fatal crash in
the southeast valley that they say was
caused by an intoxicated driver
investigators report a
64 year old woman  he was crossing the street inside the
marker when he was hit by
36-year-old albert coins when he remained on the
scene after the mishap and according to
officials he was under the
influence of alcohol for which he was
arrested
[Applause]
but more
and the king of rock and roll  elvis presley
today would be 86 years old fans
of the artist went to graceland in
memphis tennessee where the idol lived
to offer him his traditional annual tribute
alves was 42 years old when he died in 1977
and starting this monday there will be changes in
the test centers of kobe 19  here in
the valley hours and days of
operation will change at some of the
test sites  for a complete list
and the requirements and schedules of each one
visit news now dotcom under the
coronavirus section
and now we go through with a preview of the
temperatures for our region the
cloud cover from yesterday continues to recede and
there will be a drop in temperatures
this afternoon we can see  maximum
temperatures in the 60 degrees in some
places but most of the valley will
remain in the fifties so we
close our brief informative
news now in spanish I am cristian
cásseres happy friday
[Music]